hi everyone um so kind of wondering how
to start this talk off and I was advised
that it's always best to start off from
a place of truth so in that spirit of
honesty I'll guess I guess I'll start
off with my truth and that is that
sometimes well to be honest a lot of the
time when it comes to the web I actually
have no idea what it is that we're doing
I have no idea what it is we think we're
doing and those moments of total
confusion tend to hit me both as a
designer and a user alike so as a user I
find myself often confronted with this
wide array of product most of which are
practically interchangeable and neither
of them really make much difference to
the core task that I've been trying to
do with them and often even when I do
subscribe to any of these products any
of these services I find myself quite
literally afflicted by upgrades and
changes that are poorly communicated and
quite frankly don't seem to have any
real benefit to myself and are
definitely an example of feature creep
which concerns me as a designer because
certainly on the local level there's
obviously the impact on the user's
direct experience we think about loading
times and I'm also particularly
concerned that this plaque these
plethora of services often aren't much
more usable than the other they're
certainly not particularly accessible
especially when you consider in the
context of the EU you have about 26% of
EU citizens who self-report that they
live with some form of disability and
certainly these products aren't any more
ethical which again is a massive concern
especially when you're considering
whether that's in time in terms of the
amount of time and attention they demand
from the user to the security of the
users information even just to how they
communicate what is connected
and by using the service where the data
is coming from where the data is going
and when you put that in terms of the
global context you know when you think
of all these products and services which
are taking up means or service space
which has a huge environmental cost if
you think about that over 70 million
servers which contribute what like 2% to
all greenhouse emissions not to speak of
the impact of the production lifecycle
of the hardware on our environmental
biological ecosystems as well as the
poorest of the global population and so
in that spirit of fascination and
confusion fascination because like many
of us here I am someone who is genuinely
excited and interested and fascinated by
technologies and I really want to take
this opportunity to slightly provoke us
as a community and start asking
ourselves firstly what are we actually
doing here and really to get into how
are we doing it so yeah I'm sorry but
it's that time of the day and what we're
going to talk about is design a bit of
contact warning the next slide and has
some geometric black and white
animations so I'm but I hopefully I
won't linger on that too long so design
what is design well when I was for me in
the context of this talk I'm
fundamentally talking about
problem-solving so when I talk about
design and implicitly designers really
I'm talking about those of us who are
creating something with an intent so I
must much speaking to those of us who
are back-end engineers as I and for
those who are API developers and user
interface designers to quote if you're
someone who moves things from an
existing condition to a preferred one
you are a designer
and so if to design is to provoke
movement questions arise such as well
where are we moving - what are we moving
from and perhaps more importantly what
is it that we're actually moving so if
we look at this ecosystems we think
about the things we are trying to move
one of the most obvious things I am as
people we're trying to move modes of
behavior ways of understanding these are
all conditions that we may well either
be asked by our product owners by ID
aters by innovators to change or they
may well be things that we ourselves
wish to move and so often when we start
trying to understand where people are in
order to understand how we could
potentially shift their behaviors and
their ways of thinking we tend to map
out their experiences in this particular
way we tend to think about what they
think and what they feel and what they
say and what they hear what they say and
what they do and by doing so what we're
trying to do is to get a sense of the
complexity of the human the complexity
of the person who will be using our
services and our technology and I say
complexity in there's in fact a clue in
the way I phrased some segments of the
map because often in reality what we
find is that this is riddled with
paradoxes
there are paradoxes between the way
people think and and how they feel
between what they say and what they
actually do between the things they
think they see or observe and the things
that they actually act on and take note
of so here we have one way of trying to
understand the human that we are as
designers are trying to influence but
already there's a major pitfall that
were all susceptible to and I suspect
given that there are fascinatingly
confusing state of things we ought to
frequently give in to ultimately what
happens is that we
to limit the way that we're mapping
these our users way when limit the way
we imagine and understand our users too
much in terms of the problem that we
think we're trying to solve ultimately
what that means is that we are in
adequately framing the person who we
think we're trying to serve and
ultimately this is the source of the
problem
inadequate framing of the person leads
to an inaccurate framing of the problem
because ultimately understanding people
is meant to help us frame problems
better to generate better outcomes to
quote it's easy to make bad choices when
there aren't many choices to begin with
and that is impacted by our inadequate
framing of the person because ultimately
if the problem we think we're trying to
solve is all there is her life the
universe and everything well
we'll hang on no because it isn't
ultimately if our job is to move things
into a preferred condition it's vital to
understand the current condition because
humans don't just exist in relation to
the problems that we think we're trying
to solve
in fact as humans we exist in relation
to many other interfering mental mental
and social models we exist in relation
to many other environments natural
social and built and one of those built
objects one of those built environments
is the other object that we're trying to
move over to a preferred condition and
that other object is the web now at its
most basic the web is created by
computational devices communicating with
each other by an agreed protocol but I'm
often being quite curious because if you
think about the map we use to try to
interrogate the experience of the human
what happens if we try to use that same
map to understand the experience of the
web and often what happens is that in
many ways we see that the same paradoxes
apply for all that the Internet is
created of communications between
computers sending bits of information
between each other yet this information
regardless of the fact that it's broken
down into its binary components is
nonetheless combined with the physical
structure of the network the physical
structure that actually arises out of
already existing evolving geopolitical
and economic structures and it's that
which contributes to some fundamental
inequalities such as which languages are
more dominant who has access to the web
in the first place when they do and how
so to clarify what's going on is that
the inequalities we see on the web
actually come from the material nature
of the web these inequalities that
impact what people get to read what they
skate to see how secure their data might
be and indeed how safe they might be as
a citizen of their country and it's the
materiality of the web which is where as
designers our concern for the
environmental impact of the web should
also come in after all all those servers
are what helps to contribute to the fact
that the web is the fourth largest
producer or CEO to after the United
States China and India and so if we go
back to our analogy of design as dynamic
what you have are is an object that's
made up of a relationship between the
human and the web where our solution the
thing that transmits movement to the
system to move this relationship to a
different way of being actually becomes
a part of the system ultimately the
intersection of the web the user
whatever additional dynamic so we create
will create in turn another emergent
system and like all emergent systems it
is complex in nature
it is chaotic and unpredictable arises
into huge and often unfor unseen our
phase shifts and sometimes it's often
what results in cases like this so this
is a screenshot from a developer Jackie
RCA who was one of those who noticed the
fact that the facial recognition
software that Google had initially put
in place wasn't capable of realizing
that black people were in fact human
beings and instead categorize them as
gorillas and I always point to this
example partly because it's pretty
famous and most people have at least had
heard an inkling of it but I think in
terms of what I'm trying to talk about
in terms of designing for this human and
web system it highlights some of the key
assumptions that we tend to infect our
solutions with it highlights assumptions
about what aspects of the human need to
be taken into consideration and
particularly in the case of this example
highlights our assumptions about our
ability to manage and solve any
resultant errors in the service we think
we provoke we're providing seeing this
kind of stuff is fascinating for me as a
user experience designer because it's
enough to make any anyone cry like that
do you even design but really a lot of
what's happening is that we are too busy
framing our design research into how it
directly applies to the problem we want
to solve we're ignoring the noise
because it doesn't seem to be relevant
and this is something that I myself am
totally susceptible to I'm from the UK a
society that still massively riven by
class-m and racial inequalities and even
eyes
tones will fall prey to this I have to
remember that actually for myself as a
middle-class cisgendered University
educated a bored citizen of a first
world in Anglophone nation that so much
of what I might perceive as just
additional and extra bits of information
essentially the noise in my research
data is not in fact noise what's going
on is simply my relative privilege
impeding my ability to interpret the
data it's not noise it's just your
privilege talking the designed object
after all is a revelatory object it
reveals our assumptions about people our
assumptions about how we think the world
works or indeed how we think it doesn't
it certainly isn't neutral and as a
child or humanity technology can never
be neutral so when we're designing
things that will be used by people we
need to check how we think about people
and how we think about the world we all
after all have multiple facets to
ourselves and as to how was seen by
society so the worker kimberlé crenshaw
for example who invented the term
intersectionality that work actually
came out of rigorous analysis about the
way the united legislation in the united
states at the time couldn't really
account for the discriminatory
experience faced by black women in the
workplace because as people who were
both black and women the legal system
couldn't adequately frame their
experience being a combination of sexism
and racism and so similarly like that
legal system our technologies may not be
able to adequately frame with the
experiences of our users and could as a
result put them at risk from the
inequality that they already interface
with in their society and in fact that
our technologies will in turn
interface and be impacted by it's not
noise it's just your privilege talking
so I promise that this would also have
something that's a bit practical and so
I guess now the most obvious question is
okay well hey you teaching us how to
design what can we try instead so
firstly what I always like to say is
well first I'll start by reaching out
and opening up reach hours to get your
technology looked at get your technology
considered from a different perspective
if you're living in a university city or
nearby a research interest Institute
find out who your local digital
humanities academics are get in touch
with ethnographers and social historians
who will have experience in analyzing
hundreds of years worth of data
concerning human behavior and the
interaction with technology if your city
has an impact hub or a makerspace reach
out to them and get them involved in
critiquing idat and testing your
technologies the solutions that you
think might help them working in machine
learning well join the algorithmic
Justice League to help you query that
training data or at least to raise
concerns that you might have about how
well the data has been as the data set
has been formulated if you're already in
development phase or think about pushing
upgrades use gamified interventions like
the tarot cards of tech to help you
design and improve architecture that is
flexible enough to handle the various
situations that even a single persona
can find themselves in and even if it's
almost too late to bring in those kind
of changes to your ways of working at
the very least it will help you be
honest about where the potential
security and social risks for users will
be the next tip I give is to design your
technology as a
service and what does that mean or what
it means to paraphrase the service
design network is that think about how
you're designing the infrastructure then
communication between the different
levels of your system and the material
components of the service will interact
not just with the people who are using
the service but also with the service
provider your solution is in many ways a
go-between between two already existing
complex systems design the whole
lifecycle design what happens when it
breaks design what happens when it
degrades design how people will deal
with it if they have issues with it what
happens if one of your users dies what
happens to their data then design design
think about this the other thing that
might also be helpful as the kind of a
fun little exercise actually map out the
experience of your solution as though it
were a person and I'm honestly not
trying to be cute actually pinned down
how is it that your solution that thinks
how does it feel
what does it think about its users what
is the mental model of your technology
what can it understand about people are
they just first name and last name do
they use social media can it see what
other data what other things the user
transmitted across the vast rate vast
ecosystem of the web what does your
technology see and hear from other
services and other technologies most
importantly Howard will I would advise
you to remember and to understand the
person the human being as
multi-dimensional and remember that
complexity in any complex system comes
from the most basic component the
variations that exist within that system
are often what lead to wide divergences
in behaviors and phases and then and for
us as designers of the web that
complexity comes form of the human so
think about how their context informs
even their non
task-related needs is it always safe for
them to use social media logins to gain
access to your service and if they have
done can they are they empowered to
change what information is displayed one
of the things that always frankly annoys
me quite significantly as if I'm using
if I'm logging into a solution and I can
if example use my Twitter handle to log
in and yet I can't change the image I
can't change it into say a generic
avatar in case I don't actually want
people to realize that it's the same
person on Twitter and or Meetup or
wherever else who's also using this
particular product so what are the
issues well how do they report if
something goes wrong with it
with the solution either in terms of the
other users they're encountering or with
the solution itself can you build this
at scale always consider how your
solution will be used in the context of
the other someone as different from you
as possible consider how your tech might
be used by or impact someone who was
homeless someone who was a refugee
someone who is a woman someone who is
trans someone with varying a power
supply in their local context and if it
seems tokenistic well to be honest that
says more about your technology than the
design process if considering the
multiplicity of human experience comes
across as tokenistic quite frankly
that's because your technology is
already objectifying people so check
yourself do people actually need the
service that you think you're providing
if you are truly convinced that people
do then I'm afraid you need to be ready
to get uncomfortable and start engaging
with the realities of human existence a
really great way than to account for
this complexity as what often gets
called design jamming and you know the
famous saying how it goes if you can't
beat them involve them even before user
acceptance testing get into the habit of
co-creator
doing design jams with users your
testers and your auditors what you will
end up with are technologies that are
much more resilient and have a more
durable end-to-end service because
instead of having to react to the
complexity once they are out there in
the ecosystem they have already imbibed
that complexity as part of the basic
architecture of the product and if you
need how and you may well do and that's
fine there's a huge service design
network out there that's filled with
friendly and really exploited service
and user experience designers who are
itching to help you design the
technologies of the future which can
still be human centered ethical and
accessible by 2020 it's estimated there
will be 200 billion devices connected
devices exchanging zettabytes worth of
data and yet if the foundational
technologies that help us analyze and
extract a value from this data to create
our products if those foundational
technologies are built in hope rather
than on the evidence about our
intersectional realities that means we
create an ever greater power lot of
digital gunk that no one really needs
increases our already massive
environmental deficit and puts us all at
increased risk from cyber and social
political attacks
I implore you furfle as a fellow
designer think broader than your problem
think broader than your screens think
broader than your personas think broader
than your neat little plugins think
water make inclusively and start
designing better thank you